speaking of things that cost a lot but
are super exciting uh page two no we'll
wrap it up this is there's more than
page two
what do you think this is
this is uh
Louis de broiley's thesis was three
pages long and he won the Nobel Prize
for the wave particle duality so you
know size Matters in different
dimensions in life I think the the
lessons I've learned about life is the
shorter the paper or the shorter the
thesis some of the best ideas in this
world now not to sound like a
contradiction of Feynman a contradiction
on top of a contradiction but it could
be written on a napkin honestly
um it was just kind of what tells you
something about ideas
[Applause]